please be upstanding for the chairman of
the council
July district council full council
meeting as my chaplain is on holiday I'm
delighted to welcome former chairman of
this council hello again oh come on
good afternoon let's let's pray together
many demands and responsibilities that
face officers members of this council
let's have a few moments in which we
trust we meet in the presence of God to
pray for each other in our own personal
situations for those as weighed down by
the stresses and strains of daily life
we long that peace of mind we pray for
each other here in local government
entrusted representing the interests of
local people in their communities
throughout this district let's be aware
we make decisions which affect and
influence people's lives
help us Lord as we wrestle with limited
resources and numerous demands grant us
all wisdom insight patience and humility
that we may be equipped to Oliver trusts
this community has placed in us these
thoughts we offer in the Lord's name
amen
thank you
I call I'd like to remind of what he
please that when speaking could you
address the microphone from a short
distance away all these all these
meetings are recorded and if it isn't if
you're not picked up by the microphone
then there won't be a record of your
what you've got to say so if you just
bear that in mind I therefore move on
the first point apologies for absence I
could call upon David Buckland to report
the list of apologies thank chairman I
now invite members to make any
declarations of interest which they
might have for items on the agenda of
today's meeting yes of a personal
interest in relation to item 11 George
Thank You mr. Buckland point three
minutes I now seek a proposer and
seconder for the minutes of the meetings
held on the 14th of April and the 22nd
of May 2019 clearly the first meeting
can only be proposed and seconded by
those who were counselors at that time
Thank You councillor fielding counts the
mills proposed and seconded I assume all
those are you proposing both sets a
minute all those in favor of the first
set of minutes everybody against no
second set of minutes all those in favor
thank you very much that's carried I now
invite councillor Dixon who has already
been elected as vice chairman to come
forward to sign the statue declaration
of acceptance that office of vice
chairman and receive his badge of office
right can we have the acceptance of
office please
right ladies gentleman a small technical
glitch I suggest mr. counselor Dixon
sits down and we will just move that by
item back down the agenda until we get
the right bit of paper for Tony to sign
well therefore move on to announcements
this part of the meeting is to for
myself the leader and the head of paid
service or acting head of maid service
just to give a [ __ ] of what we're up to
since we last met
clearly my responsibilities are not to
do with the executive but representing
the council I've been here before
and in the last direction I've been
through I go scan through these quite
quickly that I've been through 26 I
think attendances on behalf of the
council both strap on both within
Stratford and without Stratford some of
which have been more formal something
less formal such as the start of the
junior Park run at the recreation ground
so very quickly through those if anybody
wants to copy this clearly they will be
available to you
you'll notice if you did have time to
read those that there have been a number
of references to China in one form or
another and I was invited to go to a
three-day conference in Beijing at the
beginning of June to talk about culture
and tourism and I took with me I was
accompanied by Helen Peters who those of
you who are were runs Shakespeare's
England and the purpose of the
exhibition was to talk about what we at
Stratford are currently doing with a
city called food row and there are two
foods in China which have slightly
complicated food road jacksie province
where we have we don't have a formal
twinning arrangement but we have a
longstanding friendship with them and
that has now become quite well-known in
China and this conference was too
frightened for me to talk about what we
in Stratford have been doing with food
row and then to see what other cities
around the world were mostly in Western
Europe were also doing with Chinese
cities and using regeneration of
industrial areas to sponsor arts culture
among others so it might recognise the
blow with a chain on Henan Peters behind
it was a very interesting conference
looking at what the Chinese also doing I
was asked to go and speak at the
Federation of masters builders at the
annual conference which actually
helpfully held in Stratford now the
master builders are not the major
developers the master builders are those
people who many years ago used to build
a significant proportion of housing in
Stratford and the rest of the country
but have now been superseded by the very
very large company countries companies
and it was what was very interesting at
that conference was how many of the
things that we have concerns about were
reflected in their own concerns where
they are trying to keep going
small builders building quality jobs and
are actually slightly knocked out the
way by the juggernaut something larger
housing companies coming through I was
invited to go to the British Museum
again on the theme of culture and
tourism and this was a uk-based
conference organised by the Chinese
embassy but looking at what venues in
the UK are doing and the attendees were
the Liverpool Metropolitan University
Museum who had just finished a an
exhibition of the Terracotta Army
not the whole lot but a small selection
and Kew Gardens British Library all of
whom regard the Chinese is a very
significant part of their future
population or future attendees so that's
me might recognise Shakespeare's
birthplace junior Park run about five
months ago mr. perfect so I can see
sitting at the back come the chairman to
actually take part in the senior part
run not in opening it but actually take
part along with the team of other people
from officers from Stratford tonight of
deserves to old to qualify for this one
because it's rather a hot day but it was
great to see a very large crowd of
children running the park run some with
quickly suitable speed and actually
called on doing all the faster nighter
the senior one but there's no surprises
there another lovely evening was
listening to Archer choristers this was
a a group of people selected from all
over work sure and it was most wonderful
evening at junior level and watch
Michael teenage level the mayor of
Stratford and I attended the AGM of the
Stratford Scouts and Town Hall and then
there were various other events which
I've listed
in the previous slide earlier on which I
attended you got the second thoughts
production top left the pillow man by
the Bearpit theater at the bear pit
a concert at the political district
Stratford Road first of all thank you
Stratford Festival beating the street at
kite and depo and imaginatively on the
benevolent fund in Warwick so that's
really the end of what I've been up to
it's normally the stage that I announce
what charities are going to do that
support for this year last year I
supported the brain tumor trust and
young minds this year I'm supporting
ships turned home nursing and I really
apologize I'm just waiting for Mission
for the other one I'll let you know as
soon as I've got the other ones approval
I will be organizing a number of events
this year last year for the first time
we recognized the annual service of
remembrance and had a service outside
this office to commemorate a project
that we put together to enumerate all
the young servicemen who died in the
First World War that list had never
existed before and we now have a
handwritten book which is outside as
well as a website naming by village and
regiment and here or even month of death
of all those people in Stratford
district who died in the First World War
it was very well received the service
outside was attended by a lot of people
and we invited students from both cares
and a junior school in my own parish to
come and read the lessons and I'm
proposing since November of the 11th and
I was on a Monday which helped us to do
the same day as a cabinet meeting that
we repeat this exercise to commemorate
the ending of the First World War
also during my year as office we will be
the country will be recognizing VE Day
on the 8th of May and I'm proposing as
the whole country will be celebrating
that this council should also celebrate
VE Day being the end of fighting in
Europe in 1945 last year
I attempted and we slightly run out of
time to introduce a small business award
for businesses across Stratford district
now the intention was it'll be for each
ward member to put up a number of
businesses possibly two or three against
strict criteria and I'd like to
introduce that again this year with
slightly more advanced notice than I did
last year so that each one of you can
put forward a business or two or three
from your Ward's which you would like to
be considered to be the most successful
business in Stratford final point I have
been working with officers and that we
have made no changes to this meeting but
in future 2sat try and simplify the
agenda so that it both councillors and
members of the public can have a easier
grasp of what is going on without having
to plow through their very considerable
links the pages that we currently have
ladies and gentlemen that sums up what
I've been up to are therefore if I can
get this to move on briefly I've
mentioned China already and foo Joe for
those of you who aren't aware of what we
have been doing there so many of you
will be aware that we received a gift of
a peony pavilion which wasn't
universally popular when it went through
planning however it has been built and
it is in China in the city of Fujio they
are building a replica Stratford it's
the Shakespeare Birthplace trust have
been working very closely with them to
commemorate the close association we
have between there
and a poet called Tang Shang Xue and
after our town and Shakespeare both died
in the same year 2,216 1616 along with
Cervantes who's the third individual in
that picture who also died in 1616 the
Spanish poet who wrote don most famous
for reading Don Quixote why are we
working with China firstly tourism now
represents about 10 percent of our GDP
and by 2025 will be an estimated of
contributing about 257 billion to the UK
economy in the UK China does not appear
in our top ten but it is second in the
number of visitors to Stratford and
that's an information coming from
Shakespeare's England the growth in word
growth of Chinese tourists has been
phenomenal from 2002 to 2017 I'm hoping
to get 2018 very shortly but when you
compare our performance to compare
Chinese visitors to France Germany and
Russia and our growth rate of tourists
coming to Stratford or the UK we are
very very much behind our two
competitive countries in Europe and
likewise against Russia now given how
important Chinese visitors artist
radford it is really important is with
China and China are fascinated and
remained to be fascinated by and we need
to keep them fascinated in William
Shakespeare and how we as quite a small
Sat town have managed to make such a
phenomenal success of our relationship
with Shakespeare and making such a
worldwide phenomenon clearly it's
nothing to do with me it's the quality
of his writing but it's how it has been
promoted over over many years
and it's really key that if we're going
to continue to stay on the top table as
a tourist venue we must ensure the
Chinese are happy to want to continue
coming here and that we we therefore
continue to market Stratford at the
highest level to China and make sure
that we still are seen as a major
European destination for them to come to
write that really is the end of my
presentation
I'm not going to hand over to I've asked
we pointed out right at the AGM there
was an outside body appointment of the
Grange Hall side them there should have
been requests for two councillors the
councillor Bromage is the other board
member for Sodom has indicated his
willingness to be the other
representative with councilor Crump
I'd like to him so I confirm I'd like to
make sure Bruce happy as Tony barometers
and independent councillor his contempt
with that appointment are we agreed
thank you I know in fact the leader of
the council and the head of paid or the
Jamie Buckland head of governance and
democracy and monitoring officer to give
their announcements
I'll be very brief I also attended the
Queen's Award for enterprise seminar I
was also present to receive the petition
on climate change the other major event
that I attended dear in the previous few
weeks has been the LGA conference and
it's just worth saying that at the
conference one of the key issues there
was the obvious uncertainty around at
the moment that's both in terms of
brexit and in terms of who was going to
be Prime Minister there was an awful lot
of discussion on the financial pressures
facing councils which are substantial
there was a lot of discussion around
climate change it does give a real
opportunity to do networking in
particular with Warwickshire County
Council and all the district councils in
Warwickshire but as well as that read
each Bromsgrove and which Aven and the
reality actually is we are going to have
to work more and more closely with these
neighbouring councils so it was really
useful to be able to talk to both the
chief executives and the leaders of the
council good afternoon I've got three
announcements this afternoon firstly
I've received a letter from the local
government Boundary Commission for
England now they've undertaken the
review of our elektra by award and have
identified a slight imbalance on 11
wards now we will be referring this
matter to for consideration to the audit
standards committee now consider on the
29th of July but it potentially could
lead to review other boundaries but not
until 2023 secondly I just wanted a
couple of pieces of good news so as from
the amounts that we have secured
accreditation under BS seven nine five
eight and the surveillance cameras
commissioners code for our CCTV
operation so
involved in CCTV and finally that we
have received our best ever results for
the Elizabeth House reception survey
with over 95 percent satisfaction from
those two abuser survey last year thank
you Thank You chairman this is an
announcement by me I'll be on behalf of
the councillors monitoring officer and
it's about the stratford-on-avon
District Council investigation
stratford-on-avon District Council has
zero tolerance in relation to any form
of discrimination including alleged
sexism the District Council they're
thought takes any shoots allegations
extremely seriously and has already
committed to fully investigate the
concerns about elected members conduct
raised by a former employee and the
other gay other allegations made about
the culture of the council all staff and
counselors has been contacted to invite
those with similar concerns to come
forward to help with the investigations
although no formal complaint has been
received detailing the initial
allegations due to the seriousness of
the allegations and external
investigator has been appointed the
investigations have been conducted under
the members code of conduct in respect
of the individual members concerned once
the investigation is complete then
subject to any legal requirements the
intention is to publish the report in
full where there is evidence that a
member has breached the code the report
is likely to be published by the end of
September while the investigation is
ongoing
no further comments or statements will
be made thank you
Thank You mr. one film right we now move
on we'll go back I now invite councillor
Dixon to sign his acceptance of office
of vice chairman which we now do have
the correct piece of paper in front of
us Thank You chairman i anthony Dixon
having been elected to the office of
vice chairman of the Council of the
District of stratford-on-avon
hereby declare that I take that office
upon myself and will duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability I
undertake to be guided by the
stratford-upon-avon District Council's a
code of conduct a bertoldo members
conduct in the performance of my
functions in that office
congratulations said it right we now
move on or back to gender where we were
and we're now at public participation
and the first personal call is miss
cappella you've received a written
response to your question do you have a
supplementary question would you like to
come up please to the table over here
don't could you move a chair up for
No and if you press the button in the
middle and the red light should come on
if you'd like to article so cut your
supplementary question it's the council
willing to sacrifice
as your question was answered by the
leader of the council I will transfer
that question on to him I think that is
a very interesting question an awful lot
will depend on what our residents
actually want and whether our residents
are willing to sacrifice economic growth
to tackle climate change I've got
absolutely no doubts in my mind the
Tecla climate change will have a very
significant impact on everyone we do
live in a democracy and people have to
make democratic choices so the council
is well responds to what people actually
think and how they vote I think it will
be very interesting going forward as to
how the population of the UK actually
makes the trade-offs thank you
thank you Miss Kapila miss Appleton
you received response to your question
would do you have a supplementary
question if so could you come forward
and the microphone please and ask your
supplementary question thank you and
first of all I like to say Thank You
councillor Jefferson for your response
and willing us to review the community
involvement especially response to the
last question given that the Committee
on climate change has said that the UK
is lagging far behind what is needed
even to meet previous emission targets
and that even David Attenborough has
come out and said that we have 18 months
it's not this climate crisis out does
the council believe that it will be
prudent to talk about a climate crisis
and not climate change and to commit to
a date for zero emissions by 2030
thank for that question I will pass it
on to counsel Jefferson as you responded
to your previous question thank you
I think an awful lot of these points
will be covered in the debate on the
notice of motion later I think one
observation I would make is that if we
only have 18 months to sort out climate
change we're going to fail thank you
Miss Hamilton
I now call on miss Daniels you've
received a response to your question
miss Daniels are you well done
do you have a cell familiar question and
if so would you like to come up as
elders have done well done John to read
out your supplementary question please
yeah well I think my first question was
a slightly misunderstood so could I ask
is it possible for school children or
kinds in high school its eco group to be
involved in the planning process of
making Stratford carbon-neutral the more
environmentally friendly as before I'm
going to ask the leader council
Jefferson to answer your question
youngster is yes
[Applause]
and one for coming up and I think it is
very important I would say that we all
hear what younger members of society
we've got to say so if you want to
encourage any of your other comes
colleagues to come to this always
they're not breaking school rules we
would be delighted to hear from them if
they've got any questions they'd like to
ask us so anyway well done mr. Scott
you've had a response from counsel
Jefferson to your question from the way
you're coming up you've also got a
supplementary as well mr. chairman
councillor Jefferson before I put my
supplementary question I would just make
like to make a few comments
I'm a retired chartered engineer and I
have followed the climate story for more
than ten years and I am now I have
become more terrified and angry at the
lack of action terrified the
consequences for Humanity for this lack
of action and angry at the lack of
action I am pleased that the council is
now considering declaring a climate
emergency and it's worthwhile looking at
the dictionary definition of emergency
which is something which requires
immediate action before I make the
question I would just like to make you
aware of three things this country
already has climate refugees that is in
Fairborn in West Wales the council there
has said that they are no longer able to
protect the town against the effects of
rising sea level sea level is rising
because of melting of
and I would urge council members to
Google Greenland ice sheet melting and
you will see what a horrific story it is
he doesn't feel like an emergency here
in Warwickshire in Stratford on a
beautiful day like this but I can assure
you it is an emergency and also a little
bit further away if you look at
information about the thames barrier
this planned expenditure of 10 billion
on the thames barrier to deal with a
fairly minimal amount of sea level rise
and there are now predictions that the 1
meter rise by 2010 is going to in fact
become 2 meters due to what's happening
in Greenland and elsewhere so my
question was in two parts and councillor
Jefferson has kindly replied that the
all reports consider environmental
issues but the second part of my
question was will the council ensure
that best policies are used to minimize
emission of greenhouse gases Thank You
mr. Scott
mr. Jefferson to minimize the effects of
gases and minimize emissions I would
actually just also like to make an
observation following on from your
statements I've been involved in looking
at climate change for 15 years I really
do appreciate how serious it is I was
based on the motion thank you very much
thank you mr. Scott hi mister passing
ham are you yes you are
have you you've received response your
question and you presume you've got a
supplementary question as well could I
remind you that you've got three minutes
and what does this opportunity so I like
a question but if we wouldn't mind not
to give up a speech thank you for your
response Tony it's a two page long
response I think I'm not sure that
everybody has got the actual question at
the back so I really add again Friends
of the Earth have recently published a
report showing that UK councils invest
billions of pounds of our pension money
in companies drilling for new coal gas
and oil and these make climate change
worse does Stratford District Council
pension fund have investments in fossil
fuel companies and if so is it time to
ditch these investments in dirty energy
and the response from the council as I
say is two pages long the most of the
seams look probably all of the pension
fund is invested through the work share
County pension fund and in the response
it does say that financial
considerations are the only ones that
are taken there but the response is
slightly contradictory in that Warren
see a pension fund has signed up to a an
investment policy from border and Coast
pension partnership which does include
climate change and it does say that
these investments pose significant
investment risks
and this is because with the reduction
in the cost of renewable energies like
offshore wind they are becoming cheaper
than most fossil fuels and investments
in fossil fuels are likely to be
stranded over the next few years because
nobody will want them so that's a good
question because you are really sorry
well so my question
and I've also found out that what she
spent referred according friends of the
earth have seventy four million pounds
invested in fossil fuels so it's it's
not a small amount and the fraction of
that for structure is probably 1015
million pounds so my question is
basically is the counts we're going to
look into the details of where the
crunching pension fund is invested and
if so are they will they then use all
their influence to make the investments
more sustainable and not seen fossil
fuels thank you mister passing on mr.
Jefferson
thank you I think it raised some very
interesting points just as a background
it is becoming more and more obvious
that investment companies are taking a
greater interest in sustainability and
now are looking very hard at the
investments in fossil fuels but
generally with a view to reduce in them
the pension fund the wardship pension
fund obviously has to work within some
of the constraints that are set on it
like maximizing an investment return
whether or not those constraints are
appropriate at the moment I don't know
but they probably need reviewing there
is also an AGM of the warwickshire
pension fund which people are entitled
to attend
might be made directly to the pension
fund itself right we have no more
questions from the public
so we'll now move on to 0.78 agenda we
have already received a petition from
mr. nori which is here signed by a
significant number of people I think
it's over a thousand people
mr. nori I think I did see you outside
are you very well would you like to come
forward and address the meeting and
you've got three minutes if that's okay
and we're delighted hear what you've got
to say okay okay first of all I'd like
to thank the council chair for inviting
me to address you today I'd like to
thank the council staff who advised us
on that petition and you handled it I'd
also like to thank councilor junit for
bringing this motion today and councilor
fitter for a second in it and I'd like
to thank councilor Jenny fragile II for
her work on the motion and for our
campaign we're asking you to declare
climate emergency because climate
emergency is the correct name for the
situation people are already dying and
been told they'll have to leave their
homes in Britain today we have increased
storms floods heat waves and droughts
infrastructure has been destroyed and
crop yields are down and our natural
ecology has been damaged the thing is we
don't know how bad things are going to
get the earth takes time to warm and a
certain amount of warming is already
locked in and by virtue of the carbon
we've released in the past we don't know
if this release of carbon will be enough
to trigger feedback mechanisms and
tipping points that will potentially
make global warming self-sustaining
perhaps irreversibly it seems that in
light of this scientific uncertainty we
the real message is we need to reduce
our emissions as quickly as possible the
real danger is of runaway global warming
that would be beyond our power to
we need to act as urgently as possible
to enter emergency mode to act as if we
would if a house was on fire as Gretchen
Polk says because essentially it is a
petition also calls for the council to
target greenhouse gas neutrality by 2030
and I understand that amendment has been
proposed that will do this effect it's
important in tackling climate change to
maintain a sense of realism and not to
demand what's impossible but the thing
about societies is that they're made up
of people and the bounds of what is
socially possible change as people's
attitudes change to target greenhouse
gas neutrality by 2030 is no doubt well
beyond the council's own power zone by
virtue of its budget and its legal
powers but by resolving to plan for 2030
the council can exert leadership can
show a sense of emergency that is more
likely to win buy-in from members of the
public and which will put pressure on
the government to pass moat motions that
will make these targets more possible
we're asking the council to declare to
to exert leadership through this motion
not necessary to achieve everything
through its own actions as it stands I
think we'd probably all believe that the
government's own 2050 target is too
remote
we know that politics is incredibly
short term these days 2050 is
effectively on the Nevernever
we know that the the report on which
this 2050 target is based already it
includes a 60 percent rise in aviation
so we have reason to believe that the
government and the Committee on climate
change is not being as as radical and as
urgent as it could be and we know that
even if the government did manage to to
reach this 2050 target it would only
give us a 50% chance of staying within
1.5 degrees
effectively a toss of a coin I don't
know I don't really fancy staking
my child's future on the toss of a coin
so we humbly I urge you to pass both
motion and amendment thank you
[Applause]
Thank You mr. nori you need to get a
faster clock you were thirty seconds
over but well done I think we all
appreciated hearing what you've got to
say and I'm sure it will inform all
members for the forthcoming debate that
we will shortly be having so we've
received we've received that petition we
now move therefore on to the motions on
notice but firstly I get a call upon the
council's monitoring officer mr. Grafton
to provide an overview of debating rules
to insist our new members and that's a
reminder to all those les new members as
to the rules for a debate on this of
this nature mr. Grafton
so what is to follow in a few moments
might be rather confusing for some
particularly members of the public who
haven't been to a council meeting before
we do have debating rules which are set
out in our Constitution but you won't be
asked to read them or pass an
examination about in this afternoon
because I'll give you a quick synopsis
of the rules so the first rule is that
I'm afraid that only counselors can
speak during the debate that's to follow
but ask you please to respect the views
that are given by counselors whether you
agree with them or not please pay the
some respect
we do have a rule allowing the Chairman
to suspend the meeting if there is
public disorder but honestly I'm not
expecting it the police respect
counselors and what they have to say as
you'll see on the agenda there is a
motion that set out with a proposal for
a council decision and the proposer and
the second will be the first people that
you will hear from I'm also aware that
there is an amendment coming forward to
the motion I'm advised that that will be
coming forward quite early in the debate
assuming that that is seconded then the
focus of attention during the first part
of the debate will be on that amendment
incidentally the mover of the original
motion that's the one that's on you
papers will have the final word before
there is a vote on the amendment if the
amendment is passed
you know the words as a majority then it
replaces the one on your papers and if
there's no other amendments then there's
a second vote to decide whether or not
the council resolves that assuming that
the amendment is defeated then we move
back to the motion that's on your agenda
there could be other amendments coming
forward we don't know members in each
part of the debate can only speak once
so once on the amendment once if the
amendment is defeated going back to the
original motion they have a maximum of
five minutes to do so I'm sorry to
confuse with all these rules but that's
the way that we we do things in the
council and I hope that makes it a
little bit easier for you hearing what's
going on
thank you I'm just going to stop those
and we've got any questions from the
monitoring officer arising what he's
just said so every clearly understands
the rules are set out in the
Constitution good are there for call on
councilors June 8 and footer to propose
and second the following notice of
motion yes I'm putting forward the
notice of motion as it is on the on the
paper okay putting forward the notice of
motion as it should not paper do I speak
at this point can we confirm that notion
motion notice it is seconded mr.
chairman I'd like to second the motion
as it is on paper would you like to give
us an explanation about the motion yes
I have a sense of deja vu today because
it was actually in 1993 26 years ago I
was a much younger counselor and asked
for support for local agenda21 I got
that support from across the party
across the council and this council then
went on to become a national leader
setting up an energy efficiency charity
and winning awards for work with local
businesses on resource efficiency indeed
a council an officer from this council
went up to sit on to set up an
international resource management
company and I reported and sent were
submitted and the further report in 2003
but we've moved on we have now got
warnings that are not more serious than
we thought at the time both the IPCC and
the UK climate change committee have
warned that we're still not meeting the
targets needed to prevent a dangerous
rising warming they've said that a
limited global warming to 1.5 degrees C
is still possible but only if there is
ambitious action from national
sub-national authorities and local
citizens and today I'd like to see this
council rise to that challenge local
government has a long history of
leadership setting standards pulling
together community networks supporting
local businesses and coordinating
actions and it can aim for a 2030 carbon
neutral target as one of those aims if
it so wishes we can use the planning
system even more effectively to address
climate mitigation sustainability and
resilience we can support community
energy renewable energy Drive the
provision of electric vehicle charging
support and encourage low carbon public
transport take action on air quality
biodiversity fuel poverty be innovative
with our local waste and resource
strategies but we need more we need to
lobby government to give us powers and
resources to do what we do well I want
to see high standards for new built
homes that are future proofed with
low-carbon heating
and world-leading levels of energy
efficiency we need their resources made
available to future-proof our existing
homes a report from the association of
for public service excellent has made
clear that local log authorities need to
take an organization-wide response to
action but they also need resources that
they can deliver for their residents we
need to make it clear to government that
they also have to do their bit the CCC
and Lord eben have just reported that
there are no areas where the government
can be said to be currently planning
properly of twenty five targets
announced this year work on ten has not
even started and central funding to help
businesses and regions adapt has been
slashed and that is despite the fact
that 11 years ago the chief scientific
adviser to Defra Professor Bob Watson
warned about the prospect of a four
degree rise if action was not taken then
climate change will bring with it more
extreme weather more flood risk and
conversely more water shortages it
threatens crop yields and increase in
insect borne diseases and plant diseases
we can rise to this challenge we must
rise to this challenge for the sake of
future generations we need to encourage
innovation we need to carry people with
us we need to set targets and we need to
have a plan of action it's too easy to
be daunted by this challenge but it is
humans that have caused this crisis but
we can also fix it we can leave a legacy
something of which we can be proud we
are smart we can be bold we can keep
this district a great place to live if
we support the right policies the right
innovations and the right attitude and
it is for us to deliver now since I put
this motion the number of councils
declaring a Clariant emergency has risen
to over 130 we're not alone we're part
of a dynamic future Network so let us
get working today let us set ourselves
targets
but remember that while targets are
useful they do not themselves reduce
emissions we need to deliver actions a
declaration of climate emergency here
today must turn intent into tangible
carbon reduction actions so I ask you
today to support this motion but I ask
you further I ask you to deliver thank
you
councilor [ __ ] council Jefferson Thank
You chair can I just say that I welcome
this motion and I'm pleased to see
cross-party cooperation on this issue I
think it is very urgent that people take
action on climate change I think not
meeting the targets will have a very
negative impact on our residents the one
thing I would make clear though is it's
one planet climate change is a global
threat what we do in the UK is little
compared to China the USA and India it's
worth noting China's restarting
coal-fired power stations and Baer
builds more Indian companies have just
invested in the development of the
largest coal reserves in Australia
Australia allowed it an awful lot of the
impact of climate change is already
baked in inertia will continue to drive
climate change according to the
Committee on climate change current
global planners give only a 50% chance
of meeting not one point five degrees
but three degrees
that's how serious it is there's
considerable uncertainty of the impact
of climate change already in the system
to give an example the potential
collapse of the Antarctic ice sheets
remains the largest single source of
uncertainty in projections of future
sea-level rise over the last three years
the Antarctic ice sheets have lost an
area equivalent to the size of Mexico we
should also mention the Greenland ice
sheet that's been raised already this
afternoon we're melting appears to be
accelerating if the entire Greenland ice
sheet melted that will be the equivalent
of a 7 point 4 meter rise in sea level
if we look at local governments role
we do indeed have a role to play we have
as much a role to play in adaptation as
we do in mitigation it's well worth
noting what the Committee on climate
change said to prove them to plan
adaptation strategies for scenario four
degrees C but there is little evidence
of adaptation planning for even 2
degrees C government cannot hide from
these risks I would absolutely agree
with this we should be prepared to take
whatever action we can then push given
with scenarios
outlined the impact of the 4 degree
increase in temperature by 2100 under 2
meter rise in sea level while the impact
we can take any action we can take on
mitigation will be limited the impact
locally we can have them up the
adaptation with a substantial body is on
climate change you're pretty clear it's
been a major issue for decades as of now
the impact will run well beyond 2100
there is in general in my view a
complete lack of understanding of the
scale of change needed and the time it
will take this talk of replacing gas and
oil fied central heating in homes
there's about 25 million residences in
the UK over a 10-year period that will
be converting two and a half million a
year even though ain't over the 30 year
period he's eight hundred thousand house
yet there's no plan on how to achieve
this cost of tackling climate change has
been estimated at a trillion I think
it'll probably be more an increase in
income tax at all levels raises about 6
billion take 1 trillion over 30 years
means of income tax increase of 6p we're
all going to have to pay to tackle
climate change and the bill could be
substantial
what I quoted was over 30 years what a
financial impact would be doing it over
ten years I leave to your imaginary
also the impacts gonna hate butcher
sooner than most people realize it would
be much greater by one recent estimate
by 2050 climate of Birmingham will be
similar to modern-day Paris maximum
temperature in the warmest month will
increase four and a half degrees
centigrade mean annual temperature
change will be only one point four so
again that's going to affect directly
everyone under 50 2016 climb Committee
on climate change estimated the impact
of flooding risk on properties would
increase from eight hundred and sixty
thousand today to 1.7 million by the
twenty 80s that's with a four degree
increase the latest estimates of sea
level rise our record would increase
that noticeably same report said
enhanced levels of adaptation can offset
offset 70% of the increasing risk with
four degrees climate change it also said
and this picks up the points that were
already been made achieving this is
ambitious and will require concerted
action it's also likely to require
significant additional investment I
would agree with that same report said
water supply deficits are projected to
be widespread by the 2050s honeyed then
went on to say it once again other
tuitions projected to have the potential
to substantially alleviate future supply
deficits however it also said the
feasibility of implementing specific
adaptation messages measures may be a
significant challenge it's not hard to
see why I'm a strong supporter of
adaptation because we need to take
action now to offset those risks that
are coming right down the track cutters
I do think in terms of getting the
message across I think if we project a
2-meter rising sea level that means that
many existing communities can't be
defended I think we need to identify
which can't be defended and tell the
residents because that would really
start to get the message home hard
locally assume it's a rise in sea level
will begin to impact on Gloucester and
Tewksbury that's really getting close to
home so I'm very much in support of the
motion but I do think we ought to pay
perhaps more attention to adapt ation
how we are actually going to cope with
the changes that are already in train
the perhaps we have in the past thank
you
Thank You councillor Geoff
councillor forchick I think you've
indicated you mister speak thank you
we want to obviously Strafford's a
riverside town along with Biddeford
Ulster wells born ships to the numerous
villages along the routes of different
rivers in this district this year alone
580 homes were evacuated in Waynflete in
edinburgh people had to be rescued in
boats after flash flooding
the environmental agency have said that
we need to spend a billion pound the
year to protect homes from rising
flooding because of rising temperatures
already a government report has shown
that inland flooding would cost 1.8
billion pounds a year rather than the
first thought of 700 million if no
action is taken the Environment Agency
also predicts for every pound spent on
flood defense will result in 9 pound
saved if those are in place and I
believe that traffic District Council
needs to also recognize that smarter
town planning is needed so that our
buildings and transport networks are
more robust to cope with flooding for
example porous paving and green roofs
also leaving room for water to move into
rivers from some housing perhaps that
may be raised into the rivers and also
whole city council of have actually made
legally binding guidelines to their
planners for sustainable drainage
options flooding in Stratford district
is inevitably going to happen a climate
emergency by declaring a climate
emergency then perhaps some mitigation
plans can deal with what's actually
going to be coming thank you thank you
councillor Barker thank you today I
should be at the funeral of my friend
and mentor dr. Jeff Thomas the reason
I'm telling you that is that he was one
of the finest glacial geomorphologists
of his generation he taught me why when
I was an undergraduate and a lot of his
research underpins our understanding of
previous climate change in the
geological period I can't think of a
better tribute than actually being here
and talking about climate change which
he taught me in the 1970s one of the
theories was that we would get heading
for another Ice Age there are those of
us who have worked in the field and I
was lucky enough to do my research in
this field who for a while thought that
that might be the case and that possibly
anthropogenic climate change could be
offsetting future ice ages when you look
for those of you who have at the rhythm
of these things through the geological
era you will see that there are changes
over different period it ities that
happen naturally so there's been some
skepticism in the scientific community
that what we were actually seeing was
anthropogenic that preceded by how we
felt in the 1970s about offsetting an
ice ice age move on to the 1990 by PCC
report which is when I was an
undergraduate
and at that point the suggestion that
anthropogenic climate change was taking
place was becoming accepted so the
theories change for the facts actually
don't we still see sunspot activity we
still see bigger changes that are
brought brought on by weather shifts and
climate patterns but the facts don't
change what we're actually seeing and as
cats Lefroy Trek has said and others
have said it's increased storminess
undoubtedly we never used to get the
incredible rainfall that we now get in
such quantity so I'll give you an
example of something that has to be
built into houses now if you put
flashing around a chimney on a roof in
the 1920s it would have been about
whatever that is 8 inches nearly a foot
of that splashing now you need twice
that because the rainfall comes in such
intensity that Norda prevent water
overtopping you need to protect
buildings more and that's just one
really really tiny example scale that up
to what else we have to do with shifts
in seasons shifts in global weather
patterns we've talked about water
collection whenever I go to a planning
meeting a month to add something to a
condition I want water but two reasons I
want water but it's one because I live
in ship Stern and it slows the water
from going down and flooding the center
of the town but to the increased
storminess also means that we are
getting increased periods with no rain
water shortages are potentially an
inevitability of this which seems
bizarre but we are actually going to
have to get better at collecting water I
also think that we need to put photo for
sake for tech cells on every single new
build there's no excuse for not doing so
and support battery development which is
the way that we will then store that
energy so you can see I may be heading
in the same direction as the leader and
this was completely independently in
that I think from my own research over
the last decades
from what I've read and from what I see
now that whilst mitigation is possible
we are almost at if not already over the
tipping point which does mean Breton
emergency but we're also at an
opportunity if we adapt and humanity has
adapted over the areas and that's why I
introduced the concept of geological
time we've all seen the films with well
dinosaurs and cavemen in the same film
which I can tell you never happened but
people did move with ice at that stage
and they move out of the way of it and
adapt those those sorts of geographical
applications are probably ones that
we're going to have to make the four
degrees see rise that's been predicted
is going to make a huge difference that
is perceived to be the tipping point so
my whilst I absolutely support this I
think we do have to look further thank
you Thank You councillor can I just
remind councillors Constitution does
require speech is limited five minutes
we don't want to be here till midnight
well we might be at or midnight but move
on councillor Riley thank you Jim ocean
that we add to the end of part one the
words with an aim to being carbon
neutral across Stratford districts by
2030 Thank You mr. Riley do you have a
seconder thank you thank you
thank you
so just for everyone in the room if you
look to your your agenda papers
unfortunately they've out they're not
numbered at the beginning but it's under
motion on notice item eight over the
page part one just before the start of
what's called part two half doubt way
down the page as a passage they're
beginning therefore the council is
requested to declare and I think what's
being proposed is some additional
wording to the end of that sentence that
ends at the moment in own practices and
policies and then a comma with the aim
to be carbon neutral by 2030 am i right
in understanding that yeah thank you am
I allowed to say that I accept this as a
friendly amendment at this point okay
yeah thank you
in case counselor cargo thank you very
much chairman first I'd like to say
obviously I fully support we agree with
all the things have been said today so
far and I'm sure be more pointed unit
said about finding regs and laws and
building recs totally agree with that
we've been trying to do that sort of
thing for some time but again in these
government support on that one because
there's a big Lobby against that
particular element because it adds cost
to buildings etc so it comes down to a
few tough decisions that we have to make
as as residents of this earth this
planet and I just like to pick a couple
of those up neither is talking about
tough decisions with financial
implications that trillion pounds for
example over 30 years it is a point but
I'd like to pick one up getting a little
bit close to home here
just up the road near Ulster there's a
proposal for a gas powered carbon hungry
power substation right in the middle of
countryside now this goes against
everything we've been trying to say that
today it's actually quite desired that
anyone would even think of putting on as
it is there because just up the road
three miles from here there's a 50
megawatt power station but it's a solar
power station I was the chair of that
committee when we passed that and I was
very proud of that decision the thing
about that one is it's non polluting it
is actually sustainable so again do we
want to gas guzzling calling hungry
power stations already wants other
alternatives and it's question asked is
this tough decisions we're talking about
battery technology what are we going to
charge the batteries solar for well and
good but we know for well and good that
it's not there all the time as is wind
so we do need tough decision to be made
what about base load power generation
currently this country has around about
65 gigawatts of a power generation now
the call for obvious reasons is being
reduced because it's polluting and it's
got the the emissions problems as well
and until we get some form of
sequestration etc are we ever going to
see coal coming back I don't believe so
so what are our options fusion few years
away pumped storage for example hydro
possibly big investment do we all want a
nuclear power station these are some of
the tough decisions we can I have to
start making I'll just go on to one
other thing if I may quickly is there
plastic bottle single-use plastic
bottles they are pollutants they are
polluting our our environment terribly
but and this is one of the dilemmas that
we have to make a decision on for an
aluminium drinks bottle and I see
Jason's got his scupper district one
there well done it's about a thousand
times more co2 produced
that than it is for a single use plastic
drinks bottle these are some of the
things we have to think about it's not
an easy decision but what I do I use my
single-use drinks bottle multiple times
and I think that helps a little bit
anyway Thank You cotton I just wanted to
try and just wanted to raise a point of
order about the amendment I just want to
try and get some clarity because I just
want to understand what you're actually
trying the addition is with an aim to be
carbon neutral in Stratford districts
the preamble talks about the cancel
declaring that climate I'm a climate
emergency and having a pledge towards
local action to contribute I'm not quite
sure whether you're at whether you're
driving at buses and authority is an
organization being carbon neutral or the
entire district being carbon neutral I
just wanted to get some clarity about
exactly what it is we're being asked to
sort of look at in terms of that
amendment so if you could perhaps give
some clarity about what you're trying to
achieve that will that would help
certainly help me certainly the
intention needs to be across Trafford
district not the council therefore that
calls upon us to show leadership and
influence others as well demonstrating
by our own actions does that answer your
question an aim because I do recognize
that we can't unilaterally achieve this
substantial support from central
government to achieve that and I am
fully aware of that also I've stated
this is an aim as something to focus on
as opposed to something that we
committed to because I know that we
absolutely can't do that
thank Council Riley councillor Frederick
just before you speak
I'm just monitoring officer mr. graphs
and just to explain the implications of
the amendment being a friendly amendment
okay so so the rules say that we're the
mover of the motion on the agenda has
accepted what's called a friendly
amendment to the motion that they can do
so in remain as the mover of the motion
on the agenda so you still take the lead
on this year and you have spoken thank
you mr. Grafton I counselled Jennifer
actually I first became aware of these
as issues back in the 1970s when I was
teaching and the geography teacher was
talking to me about the change in the
monsoon rain patterns that was being put
down to changing world temperatures and
and global warming I've tended ever
since then to follow my father who we
used to call great do Goomer and I've
been incredibly depressed and
increasingly depressed by lack of action
denial and offloading and deciding never
ever to take an action even when it was
fairly easy to do I'm quite happy with
this amendment but I think it is
incredibly stretching and might not be
achievable but it does put a bit more
pressure on our thinking and where we
might actually want to go I just like to
say as a small community in Stratford
district we can do what we can do but
there are technical or technological
changes happening across the world and
even when you look at China it's opening
up all these cold fire stations but he's
also running a city on electricity god
knows where it's making that electricity
but it's coming up with technologies
that use electricity and if that
electricity can come from green sources
we
can all learn from that it's the same
with India India is is quite I've been
that it's quite a dynamic place however
in its deserts it's putting an acre upon
acre of PBS which is providing
electricity for cities close by
Cambridge has just been given a whole
chunk of money to come up with some
innovative ideas about how we can
actually begin to challenge the climate
change and begin perhaps to do a little
versal there was that lovely er I the
idea the other day plant as many trees
as you can and you've solved the problem
in 20 years
all those are possibilities but unless
we actually take a whole long cold hard
look at what we do how we do it there's
small and larger changes that we can
make partnership working with ourselves
and with overseas were actually just
about to become a global power and
independent power on the world stage
perhaps it's time we sent our diplomats
to America and to China into India to
start to nudge and change their sort of
operations I completely agree with what
the leader has said that adaptation has
to be a part of what we're doing because
we are going to be at the sharp end of
climate change which we have got to
adapt to one of the main things which
you've got to be looking at actually is
the health of our soil our soil has been
so depleted with with our farming
methods that we are we I understand I
read we've only got 20 years left of a
productive soil there's so much that
we've got to look at we can only do a
bit but I strongly urge this council
settles down and really see is what it
can do for itself and in partnership
with towns parishes County government
and international government's
councillor Pemberton
Thank You chairman when I'm thinking
about climate change I'm actually mostly
informed by the views of my 19 year old
son some members who've been here before
would have seen him said over there
filming meetings and he's fairly
vociferous in his views he describes us
as a generation we have been on a really
great binge guys with a fabulous party
we've had a great old time and the kids
over there like my 19 year old son are
the parents and they've got to clean up
the damn house now and it's all our
fault and you know what they're not
wrong and one heartening thing is that
there is some unanimity in the room yeah
I don't think there is I'd be surprised
if there's a climate change denier in
this in this particular room at the
moment but it's really easy to be self
congratulatory and say we're going to
set all these targets and we're going to
do these things and councillor Junod
quite rightly talks about showing
leadership climate change is going to
impact on every single one of us as
individuals as businesses as communities
as local authorities as nations as a
whole planet and it's not a party
political issue and it's not a
short-term issue we're in this for the
long haul
and the challenge actually our audience
are ahead of us oK we've all talked here
about different different things we
should do and targets and how we could
do this but actually every single one of
us have got to step up to the plate
because we're going to be leading our
communities and some of these changes
are going to be really uncomfortable for
a lot of our residents all of us our
lives are going to change and we are
going to be in a position where not
everything was as easy as it once was
and it's going to cost us so we're going
to have to commit and I my challenge to
everybody here is that we're not
committing for this month or for a task
and finish group we're committing for
the next 30 odd years to be going down
this route
and I why don't you start to give you
two or three examples so none of this is
policy by the way before the leader
looks at me but if we start to think and
be you know there are some inevitable
challenges when we decide that we are no
longer going to allow people who run
taxis to operate anything other than
zero emission vehicles we can't then
have people turning around and say oh
that's dreadful you've done that you've
got to support this when mrs. Miggins
wants an extension to her house and
she's got to find it she got to pay for
triple glazing she's got to play for
extended flashing and she got to have
thicker walls and it's gone it's ruined
Custer 20% more we're all going to have
to say we support all this we're not
going to be in a position where we can
then start pushing back on this we're
either all in this together or we're not
so my challenge to everybody here is
that we're all going to go down this
route it's going to meet some really
difficult decisions and there is going
to be a trade-off on economic activity
in some way shape or form but when those
hard decisions have been made there all
of us in this room have got to remember
that we stood here and we decided we
were going to embark on this route and
we were going to make a change and we
were going to make this district as
carbon neutral as possible as quickly as
we possibly can given all the
constraints around us you know we you
know councilor jr. talks about the
planning process and love to be able to
demand passive heresies overnight I do
need government support on that we also
may then have to have a trade-off around
the number of affordable houses we can
build if there are 30% increasing cost
at least in the short term there are
going to be difficult decisions so my
challenge for everybody here is are you
all prepared to sign up for the next 30
years are you all prepared to put your
party allegiances to one side that when
whoever the administration is when
difficult decisions have been made that
not everybody's going to like and we're
going to be leading as a group but
you're all going to stand up for that
and you're all going to back it so if
there's anybody not prepared to do that
now's the time because we're about to
commit ourselves for the next 30 years
and not all of this is going to be easy
so I'm quite happy with the motion I'm
desperate for us to start to make a
change because I'm just I've got a 19
year old son who looks around
what's my future gonna be and I want to
be able to look him in the eye in the
future and say we actually did make a
difference but when we do that we're all
we're all riding this train so I'm
probably that y'all gonna put you on the
spot if none of you if any of you is not
for this as an individual or as a group
stand up now and face the public because
once we've said we're doing this you
can't then come back and say these are
really difficult things so when you're
got somebody on the doorstep complaining
about you know the cost of the extension
or you know I can't you know I've got to
buy a new electric taxi in a year's time
we're all up we're all either going to
do this or not so that's my challenge
I'm up for it are the rest of you
mr. pence in five minutes in one second
counselor five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman does one say I
support what councilor Pemberton was to
say then the Committee on climate change
in july 2019 have said that it's
businesses who are going to be driving
forward becoming carbon neutral so just
to consider that all policies that we
put forward do consider are they deliver
both for local businesses and that's
where i am slightly cautious with the
amendment that council Reilly put
forward another thing is with mr.
chairman consider that the Business
Award consider an environmental some
water to the district water you consider
so for example the kid award which is
eco friendly business a special part of
a category for that Thank You councillor
Bromwich thank you sir thank you
little bit uncomfortable with this be
called the climate emergency and I'll
explain why bad calls and controversy
because actually it's not describing
he's having fun as a whole that we
should be thinking about and we've had
lots of great ideas put forward to us
already by do you think as a council we
need to actually get our heads together
and we could all vote we could actually
do with a proper grouping game together
trust party and looking at our policies
procedures as well as all the great
ideas have been put before us on this
part here and we can have some real
serious thinking there's lots of little
things as a district council we can
actually do for example my older brother
come up to me and rightfully says in the
planning process when you say about
planting trees why you planting the tree
types of trees do why are you not
planting fruit trees simple little
things sounds dad but he points out has
an environmental benefit as well as a
health benefit then when you start
thinking about the small thing
from small aid cords obviously gradient
notes so we need some serious thinking
on a lot of things we actually do as
account so I think we do need as a
matter of urgency to get a grouping
together look through our policies
tricks I'll give another example
councillor pence and bring something
issue of electric taxes now I'm going to
bring in here that I'm obviously a
licensed taxi driver right and one thing
that operators will turn out saves at
the moment for instance blend license
comes for six years that's probably
higher and by the time they pay five
years fine that's because electric cars
are such an expensive now it's not
really barber form at the moment so it's
just a little policy change that could
be needed like that you could have a
bigger long-term impact and I'm sure if
we started going through our policies
and we started looking them seriously
those little changes concerning two
great things and as most council second
we can be a model Council just through
doing small changes and small steps we
all recognize the bigger picture I hope
as somebody who's been taught us from my
days of school in the 1980s and there's
constantly looked through this right my
whole life and now emphasize this on to
a a child I foster at the moment about
the importance of looking after your
environment which we have to set
examples we have to look at different
ways of operating we have to look at
different ways of doing our policies
that so it's not just in client only
it's a whole environment we need to be
really seriously thinking about it's
even simple things like I now have
talked in the past to certain people we
all travel distracted for meetings and
yeah I've spoke to other councils a
training course I've been to they're
moving through to conferencing over the
internet but there's also really bits
small but those small things develop
into big things and I think we need to
have a proper look and a proper
heads up and now a proper think about
the direction we are going not just a
climate but the whole environmental
issue
overall thank you so much
councillor Barnes Thank You mr. chairman
deny my voice yesterday friends of the
earth came here in 1995 ever talk when I
was chairman of environmental deaths we
started the paper collections one of the
first in the county one of the first in
the country and that has moved on to
recycle a lot and we one of the best in
the country in the respect of solar
panels there were jobs to get through
planning I spent six months with 200
acres which is a big size it's a real
going around everybody having a word
having meeting it's a hospital the
church everybody so we have started we
will be moving forward and I just
thought it important to know that we are
on the way thank you Thank You constable
another cultural role I asked the
portfolio holder a year ago to replace
all the cuts with biodegradable cuts
even officers go and buy two dozen
teaspoons from the townland then holder
said
Thank You counsel Rolf casserole [ __ ]
thank you thank you I'm very short
exactly I'm from cancer laughs we are
not going to be able to fix this
we cannot a hundred percent fix the
planet in anything we try to do it's
more of a case of if everybody make the
same small changes it is going to make a
difference so absolutely we need to
start with stopping the use of
single-use plastics in the council look
at the amount of paper sitting on our
desks because not one of it is sucked
here with hardware that we could use
instead we all right can't slip n better
new have lucky old you I'll get onto
that in a minute
we our cups are actual for composting
and I've tried you can actually plant in
them and plant them in the garden and
they do actually work so with everything
that we are looking to change not just
our bigger policies with looking at
taxis looking at at ways of changing the
big things with more solar panels etc
it's looking at the small things to
start when you start with a small thing
you take the first small step when
you've got that one done you move on to
the next one and before you know it we
can be a carbon neutral district in
years I think it is possible if we all
change
[Music]
Thank You chair discussion seems to have
focused quite rightly in some areas
looking at towns on the coast and the
river fronts the one area which should
not be ignored which is a significant
part of our district is agriculture this
is a major industry for this district it
is a major aspect of our local economy
it is also a contributor and something
widely affected by climate change now my
profession is a structural engineer so I
can't claim to be an expert on
agricultural or the economics associated
with these but we must as a local
authority look to lead on their local
issues that we are affected by as this
is such a major contributor to this area
I think it's very important for the
council to recognize this impact and
what we can do in leading this locally
and nationally councillor Crump
I think counsel Adam was just taking
some of my points there but yeah I think
we do need to encourage people to buy
locally go to the local shops go to
local markets rather than getting your
avocados flown in from wherever Laughlin
and then from subject notes it could be
South America could be Africa but
whatever piece like again second cancer
Jefferson's points I think we should
encourage the government to remind all
the other countries of their
responsibilities like the US are you
like China such as injury as well so
again every one shop would say every
little house but I'm gonna be slightly
controversial here hs2 doesn't be affect
Stratford Stratford on either but it
does more award it comes within 600
meters of Southam and I think it's money
that could be spent elsewhere
it could be spent on flood protection
could be spent on encouraging
sustainable travel reducing the
dependency on cars and therefore having
a knock-on effect of improving air
pollution in our towns and even in our
villages framed by the schools all the
schools in our district how often our
cars and buses lined up queuing to get
in people encourage people to walk to
school and therefore they're walking
through experience so again why can't we
do something on that spend the 55
million a hundred billion or whatever it
is they're going to say it's going to be
spend it on something different like
that that way we can make adoptions to
local climate change so and the other
thing it's doing is well hate just to
you can tell I'm not a fan it's
destroying trees it's destroying bushes
it's dishon hedgerows on our board of
Jim can straddle my ward and their code
master
I completely 200 meters of hedge taken
down because of hey chess too and it's
absolutely disgrace so they've got my
high horse that she's hate just to money
for better better purposes and I've got
flooding portfolio at the county council
so any money spent on flooding it
certainly gets a winner votes from me
thank you
[Applause]
thank you guys for um counsel William
Huggins it's been a joy to see young
people here today but what I wanted to
say is this it's precisely because we
are Shakespeare's birthplace that we are
on the world stage this means that we
are in a uniquely privileged position in
stratford-upon-avon District Council
that we are able to lead by example and
to have quite literally a global impact
on climate change precisely because of
the decision we are about to make here
today and the actions that we
subsequently take thank you thank you
councillor Curtis thank you it's a very
small point that picking up on the point
just made the counts leading by example
there's a new counselor I walk I cycle
into town I was rather distressed and
amazed to see the accounts and carpark
there are only six parking spaces for
bicycles I think we could lead by
example and encourage a healthier
community amongst their counselors and
officers and it would be good to see
that addressed it's a small thing I
think it's very easy for us all to be
sort of paralyzed with fear like the
rabbit caught in the headlights feeling
that we can't do anything that there are
small steps that each of us can make you
how do you eat an elephant once more so
at a time
thank you that's 17 councilors so far
have spoken
I think there's been almost unique
unanimity among everybody who has stood
up does anybody else wish to add their
penny worth there's no need to it's not
compulsory but if anybody feels an area
has not been covered nope
in which case I suggest that we we
should move to them that the motion
proposed by counsel JUnit do you wish to
summarize and you I believe you have
accepted the friendly amendment friendly
amendment is a name because as I said
before targets are useful they don't
themselves reduce emissions but it's a
useful to have it for what is within our
own control unfortunately not everything
is but any action taken now can turn a
threat into an opportunity and an
economic opportunity are certainly work
in it have worked in many industries
that have made a real economic
opportunity out of the the need for
change so just to further address a
couple of things that people have said
council Barker yes I also have an
academic background not only in the last
ice age but also something the impact on
our crop plants and believe you me being
able to some of the impacts on the food
that we eat is quite quite alarming and
I've also worked in low carbon resources
and energy and they are opportunities we
are as councillor well I have been said
is a world leader in tourism industry
and we can set a world leading agenda
and we do need as has also have been
said to work with our citizens including
our young people because they are have
got the ideas the initiative the drive
and they have a lot to contribute and
they are the future many of the
solutions are best tackled locally we
have a lot within our hands and just to
say what somebody said about new build
and house
and pushing costs up well I have an old
house it is cheaper much cheaper to
build things in as a new stage but I
have an old house and I'm not wealthy by
far away not wealthy but I have adapted
my 1970s house to a fancy it's not very
much cost I have been able to do it I'm
I say I Drive a secondhand electric car
it cost me three thousand pounds but my
other members of the family also drive
electric cars and as a result a local
industry has been able to set up driving
and doing the doing up the servicing of
electric cars a new industry as a result
of the handful of us that have electric
cars so far
there were Punk points made about waste
and plastic which I hope the working
group will take up because they're
certainly they're plastic the the gas
emissions that come from plastic at
every stage of their lifecycle is an
arming and need to be tackled
agriculture was mentioned and yes there
are some things that it can be done
there and I have some information there
that could be useful
the hs2 was mentioned and the money
could be used elsewhere and there are
lots of other things where government we
could suggest a government that they use
their money more sensibly and yes let's
go and do things locally including
parking recycling including cycle routes
including there's lots of other things
so let's start start with what we can do
but also don't forget where we can put
our pressure on everybody else that
works in the district but also local
government and government central
government there are some leading
leading local councils in this field I'd
like us to be one of them thank you
thank you no I think you can say Jeunet
so I think a very robust summing up of
everything's been said I therefore
propose that we now move to the amended
motion amended by caps for riders
addition of those words that we've all
got a copy of and what we are voting on
is the heart one of the emotion and the
reason for that is that the normal
procedure with a motion the notice of
motion is just a refer to cabinet but
the decision was taken that this is so
fundamental the part one we need to have
an agreement up front in principle where
we are the detail which have a lot of
people have spoken about will be
considered by cabinet and therefore we
won't be voting on part two at this
stage will be verging on part one so I'm
going to move straight to part one all
those in favor of the motion as amended
put forward in part one please raise
your hands
any abstentions cancer fielding any
against I think that motion is
convincingly carried nobody took heed of
mr. counselor Pemberton's morning so
that is very encouraging I hope all of
you have listened I think you've had a
very clear unanimous view across the
house across the room we therefore we've
Caracara part one
[Applause]
I think we've moved quickly to part two
are we agreed
the part two for the D cell should be
referred to cabinet without further
debate
agreed thank you very much anybody not
happy with that proposal right thank you
part two is there for Karen given that
we've got a significant time people who
came specifically to hear that part of
the debate I'm proposing that we now
have a very brief adjournment whatever
just to if people wish to leave now not
counselors cuts the forchick if members
the public wish to leave please do feel
free to go so and thank you for your
contributions that debate so far
it's loose castles please resume your
seats thank you we're now going to
continue with the meeting okay we now
get the state of the meeting when we
will be actually make incisions further
decisions so we move on to cabinet
meetings and I invite councilor
Pemberton as deputy to introduce item 9
thank you very much chairman members
this is the latest in a series of
supplementary planning documents that
have been worked through to support the
core strategy members will remember that
over the last sort of six months or so
these have been brought forward in
tranches so this is the latest of those
and this enables us to formally adopt
supplementary planning documents under
Part H which do with shop fronts and
retail part I that deals with
non-residential buildings part K holiday
let's and Caravan homes part o parking
and travel per our air quality as a
respective parts of the development
requirements supplementary planning
documents the details of each of the
each of the SPD documents have been
available on the website and rather than
reproduced them in the cabinet papers
we've been able to to move to looking at
those electronically so the resolution
and the recommendation to Council rather
is that the Council formally adopts
parts H I K Oh
not
in which case we'll move spaceless
straight to the boat I'm sorry about the
speed a 0.9 although we all agree with
point 9 as proposed by cancer-promoting
we agreed thank you very much
we therefore move on to point 10 site
this comes out to the meeting cabinet
meeting this morning to consider
recommendation from the cabinet held
earlier in the day
allocation plan and a copy of the draft
minute of the meeting has been
circulated at the meeting council
pemberton as deputy leader to introduce
this item Thank You members site
allocations plan is a requirements of
the core strategy the time of the
inspectors report it was required of us
to provide a buffer of up to 20 20
percent in terms of additional homes
over and above the numbers in the core
strategy as in essence a reserve list
and you will you will note from
briefings that members have had and also
from the core strategy that there are
criteria
and yes a couple of questions if I might
I raised at cabinet this morning and you
weren't able to be there I made it very
clear and this group is very very clear
indeed but then the final and supply is
essential if we have to have it to
protect protect ourselves
however the some of the questions I
asked were about the site allocations
timetable because according to the
cabinet on the 8th of July this is now
two years that has been a two-year delay
on delivery this and it is also listed
in the cabinet papers for the 8th of
July under the key objective to see s2a
as facilitating the delivery of housing
targets so it is with some perturbation
that that I that I saw some of the
comments about that these sites are not
a starting point for the next core
strategy and that that you know that
they were extremely unlikely to be
delivered that they were not simply
going to be put forward for into a new
core strategy in the future I asked
a cabinet this morning whether or not we
could have some more reassurance that
could limit the time for which these
sites are in reserve to give reassurance
to people that are finding themselves in
particular difficult areas so for
example if the next plan review is for
2021 ten years after the start of the
current plan it would seem reasonable
that these could only be reserved sites
until 2021 and at that point their
status reverts back now I was told at
Cabinet this morning that that
reassurance couldn't be given but but
that it even makes me even more
concerned about whether or not that
cause comment that was given by the
portfolio holder that there that these
sites could not be a starting point and
for the next course strategy and are
extremely unlikely so I'd like to have
some reassurance on that because I am
very concerned and other councillors are
even more concerned than I am
could I also ask about the consultation
period as well it was just that one
thing because again I raised it to
cabinet this morning to have a
consultation brief period that runs over
the major school holiday when an awful
lot of people that will be away but also
when Town and parish councils may not be
meeting and I wanted to reassurance that
that consultation would not period would
not limit people's response to this
consultation thank you thank you very
much chairman counselor JUnit
I've been very robust about my view of
the site's allocations plan
[Music]
Thank You mr. chairman
regarding this it's actually something
that I'm going to have to abstain on
simple reason being is I've had zero
information due to the issues but I and
other councillors have been plagued with
regarding our emails regarding our
Hardware regarding not receiving
information at all I know nothing about
it
at all so because I haven't had any
information the only thing I can do is
abstain from it I missed the meeting
because I never received the invite I
haven't had the paperwork because I
haven't been out to access my systems so
actually it's something I cannot vote
either way on just because I have zero
information to vote on four of the sites
Str 11 12 14 and 16 but within the
destructor town boundary but not within
the Stratford built-up area in fact
defined as countryside in the Stratford
neighbourhood plan policy age 1 which
was agreed by the neighbourhood plan
examiner the residents of the town by
referendum and then adopted by this
council last week I had a conversation
with the chairman of the Stratford
neighbourhood plan who informed me that
the neighbourhood plan team have not
been included in the deliberations on
the location of such additional sites to
the plan whether they be inside or
outside the built-up area but I'm
pleased with what the planning portfolio
is a said in public that they hopefully
will never be built on but that does not
does not assure at least the residents
of my ward and two of these sites are in
my ward which are providing 570 homes
the neighbourhood plan has been
preserved which is what they voted for
Thank You chairman Thank You cancer
fragile II I think probably the first
thing to say is that in terms of how the
how the slight allocation plant sites
are assessed in essence it's quite a
high-level view as to can these sites
technically be delivered you know
there's a whole raft of work that would
have to go through a if the if the
reserve list came into being which I'm
quite confident very confident that it
won't come into be but this is so this
is just a really sort of high level view
he turns the consultation the officers
work on a wide range in consultation
there have been two levels of constant a
two rounds of consultation already and I
am aware that parish and Town Council's
have commented on that on the on the
site allocations plan I can't speak
clearly for the stratford-upon-avon
Neighborhood Development Group but I
will ask John care for the Policy
Officer to liaise with you just to give
you some background about any specific
consultation but there's been that the
consultation has been wide-ranging the
fact that there are J it's adjacent to
the built-up area Brandee technically
these are sites that could be delivered
so we start with a long list of sites
not tech sites but it couldn't be
delivered in any way shape or form and
then you're left with the reserve your
is left with the reserve list it is in
my view a reserve list it's a piece of
work that we have to do I'm not looking
for and this Authority is not
anticipating that we are going to have
to dip into that reserve list and that's
pretty much the sort of
suggest is we've got four speakers
registered that we get all the views and
then to respond Thank You chairman and
I've noted some of the reassurances that
has been said in responses however I'm
responding to the paper that is before
us
so I scribbled some notes but however
and I think I understand the Nature
Reserve sites and I mean press Bali up
the optimism the port for expressing
implement and we're not going to add to
settlements
however I've been put here to represent
captain Anthony Compton both villages in
the hinterland have saved them in the
document before us Knapton is to have an
additional 85 homes in Upton village
presently has 377 so that's an expansion
of 22% Fanny Compton presently has 330
homes but on this proposed of the
reserve sites of 150 this added to the
80 homes already approved but not built
plus a further 20 awaiting determination
would result in a potential expansion of
this rural war actually the leader by
75% has 175 percent greater than is at
the moment that's a higher proportion
than any other tournament village in
these proposals it's correctly argued in
this document of the infrastructure
around save them is under strain
particularly secondary education and
there are additional considerations for
my award including Knapton and Fanny
Compton villages share the same
overstretched NHS GP network the same
same than police beat and other local
salem resources including an
infrastructure joined by an a road
network centred on save them and I've
drawn you a picture of that
and clouds ought to draw the picture as
own around save them has been set out
where development should be limited
defined by a nominal catchment area of
seven college this boundary has a bite
out of it on the southern boundary which
excludes any company Compton for reasons
best known to others the boundary uses
medieval features relied upon on the
saxons by drawing a line around lost
villages to the sense villages which
substantially disappeared in the Black
Death the boundary north of the modern a
road of today on this basis
Fanny copter may not technically be in
the catchment area of Salem Salem
College but he's directly connected by
the a four to three it's quicker to get
to sadden collagen to Canton school and
as might be expected some parents from
if any competent already send their
children to Salem College the expansion
of funny Compton on anything like this
scale will be bound to place pressures
on Salem College in an opposite effect
to the stated desire of the policy it's
clearly wise to delimit development
around save them but by pushing extreme
numbers of homes to just outside a
theoretical boundary line would surely
seem unreasonable and Knapton with
additional 85 is inside that Salem
catchment anyway I can see the
desirability of the council keeping
control of our planning policy but for
my Ward's this proposal is unreasonable
I would ask the cabinet to look again at
the proposal in this respect as it
stands I'm sorry but I will have to vote
against it I would also going to say
something about the consultation period
that's already been said the portfolio
has told her told us that my parish
councils were aware of it I've spoken to
them all and they've all been taken by
surprise so I don't
and breakdown in communication Thank You
chairman thank you for indulgence Thank
You Council Rock Donald Thank You chair
I'd also like to take this opportunity
to thank you for this level of
discussion regarding the site's
allocation plan and eddington Parish
Council were reassured by your video
portfolio builder explaining the
relevance of these sites however I had
three Parish Council meetings last week
and just to follow on about the concerns
regarding the length of consultation
period the three very active Parish
Council seem to be taken by surprise so
I'm unsure about whether breakdowns are
caring but there seems to be a theme
starting I'm just wondering is there any
flexibility at all regarding the level
of consultation period because it does
fall during the holidays so just just
looking at the flexibility of that I
think will help the Parish Council to
feel engaged and also to feel that their
parish plans than the neighborhood plans
aren't being completely ignored Thank
You councillor bonds with the anxiety of
this administration is council in
actually preserving its fiber land
supply that that is extremely important
to us all my concern is this seems to me
to be a plan B and it might very well
come into play very unexpectedly if any
major mishap happens I mean we do have
the southwest relief Road which is
slightly in the balance I don't know
we're waiting for the government to say
whether it's got to finances to put into
it but if that were to fall there would
be a huge demand on these sites that we
have and I have a concern is there some
infrastructure thinking going on behind
this
we're not going to be landed with a
similar situation where you've got a lot
of houses coming in and difficulties in
actually finding roads to service them
there are schools there are doctors we
do have in the area so my concern is if
anything disasters were to happen we did
have to use these quickly are we in the
position to make sure they're going to
be properly serviced Thank You
councillor bonds Thank You mr. chairman
I did actually speak at cabinet over the
problems that I've gotten my lord in the
respective long master and the be 463 to
which were supposed to have a survey
done with a rail link but that was a
greedy cabin a few years ago this
doesn't seem to be any coordination
between the County Council
[Music]
Quinten I believe there are five places
that ships in the Junior School fire
it's still another 300 there is any high
school places no education
on the 300 because
Thank You cancer pension I should just
make it clear that this is not a
decision to adopt the system citation
inspector you've just said
and we not indicated vote against this
there is no flexibility for us asking
for any modifications at all to this
document and we can't ask the cabinet to
I'm really worried I'm I'm gonna upset
him all through this meeting so there's
no point as trying to make any
adjustments at all - what's in this
document whatsoever before it goes out
so just to break this break this down
this is going out for consultation this
is what we're proposing to put out for
consultation we are not looking to take
this away any changes to this we then
take us back at least one step in the
process so this is this is where we're
at so clearly if members can support it
going out to consultation that that
would be great for me but I wouldn't be
upset if councilor
thinking and work going on within the
development team about ensuring that the
site's come forward through a process of
action plans for the major sites and
there is thinking and wargaming if you
want to put it in that term around I
think we are to the consultation period
in order to get this for the end of the
year
okay
against the proposal
thank you very much we therefore move
right we now we want to point 12
question 1 questions in
there is still the wiring is very
fragile and the issue I just wondered at
the beginning of the season Thank You
counselor Junod do have such a question
Thank You counselor counselor Curtis
question number five do you have a
supplementary question following Thank
You counsel Jenny progeny did you have a
supplementary question to question six
Thank You counselor I think actually
that that work is at least in part
Thank You chair concerning many of our
communities have been hit by withdrawal
of ATM machines find it more difficult
to obtain cash in my village there is
only one now where we used to have four
does the council still continue to
obviously click the business are there
any change in I was on the wrong page
councillor Pendleton but he's already
answered that question
I thank I think he may have passed the
misunderstood my question we were told
on the regulatory committee last month
for more notices on hs2 are sent to the
Environmental Health Team the hs2 hybrid
bill does not exempt hs2 from
environmental regulations which has
actually been the biggest bone of
contention of with the public recently
as clans low crop recently pointed out I
was merely seeking to ensure the full
cooperation on these matters both
planning and environmental health are
fully coordinated with the council could
we please look into this again
regardless environmental
thank you very much
thank you questions for reader two
questions remember maximum three minutes
in total for each yeah right obviously
we have had many discussions about
redevelopment in two thousand pound
Center as you may or may not be aware in
the past three weeks we've lost two out
of our three big thousand cent town
center stores it is now imperative we
start well aware as well that there is a
planning application probably going to
go for the old police station so for
some more unwanted homes I think we
really need to sort out about having a
meeting with the Parish Council with my
fellow colleague Council and relevant
parties and see what we can do
I have to say two weeks
[Music]
thank you
when it comes to meetings of paper
that was an observation
to
thank you counter pemberton it'd be
great if I could not have papers but
with not getting emails I've run the
risk of might having to stay quiet in a
meeting and that's just not going to do
at all
ibaka can't access Mudkip on anything
could also can't access the papers there
either
but this week it hasn't stopped me but I
would like to ask please this is urgent
I really cannot keep missing paperwork
of meetings due to not receiving email
I'm very tempted to say that not
receiving emails and keeping his silent
could be an advantage but no I think the
probably issues of our technology have
been well raised this afternoon I think
he does too the urgency can be dealt
with and perhaps council table you would
like to interject at this point thank
you very much I've been trying to push
while I was getting appropriate in the
middle of a process with a company
called shared intelligence or actually
assessing all of our IT needs now we've
got to be able to care for others could
we could extend an awful lot of money on
something that's redundant in a year or
twos time so probably everything about
it is public money after all and you've
all heard some IT projects
and so yes please
any further questions for those who have
not asked question already in which case
we'll move on to point 40 which is a
update